AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, WIKI
HOW'S THAT NOW?
IF YOU WERE A YOUNG PERSON
WHO NEEDS GUIDANCE YOU COULD
TURN TO THE PREVIOUS
GENERATION AND DRAW ON THEIR
WISDOM AND EXPERIENCE BUT
HONESTLY, GRANDPA IS
PROBABLY DRUNK SO [BLEEP] IT,
JUST GO ON THE INTERNET,
WIKI HOW SAY SITE WITH
CROWD-SOURCE TIPS FOR
EVERYTHING ON GETTING A FLAT
STOMACH -- THERE IS IS --
TO, THIS IS REAL, HOW TO
CALCULATE PI BY THROWING FROZEN
HOT DOGS.
(LAUGHTER)
SO COMEDIANS YOUR JOB IS TO NAME
SOME WIKI HOWE ARTICLES YOU'D
LIKE TO SEE GET WRITTEN.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
YES, PETE.
>> HOW TO SUCCESSFULLY TRAP
MICHAEL PHELPS IN A TUNA
NET.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PETE.
>> HOW TO GET BETTER RATING
ON TBS AFTER "CONAN."
>> CHRIS: KYLE.
>> HOW TO SOUNDPROOF A 1987
FORD AROSTAR.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PATTON.
>> HOW TO LOSE A GUY IN NINE
DAYS.
>> CHRIS: HEY, POINTS.
PETE.
>> HOW TO TRAIN YOUR DRAGON
BUT LIKE FOR REAL.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KYLE.
>> HOW TO GET FINGERPRINTS
OFF OF A HELLO KITTY
BACKPACK.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PATTON.
>> HOW TO GET CHRIS HARDWICK
TO YELL POINTS EVEN WHEN
YOUR JOKE SUCKS.
>> CHRIS: NO POINTS.
KYLE.
>> HOW TO PROPERLY DISPOSE
OF A SOUNDPROOF 1987 FORD
AEROSTAR.
>> CHRIS: HA, HA! POINTS.
PATTON OSWALT.
>> HOW TO HIDE YOUR ERECTION
WHEN YOUR GIRLFRIEND IS TELLING
YOU A STORY ABOUT HER DAD GOING
THROUGH CHEMOTHERAPY.